the jurogan experience this is just the
most sophisticated of the strikers he's
the if you watch striking if you're a
person who likes striking and you like
set ups and stuff
what he he's doing something very
different because he's getting guys to
move a certain way he's reading you like
you see when izzy's moving around he's
reading you yeah he's seeing if he can
come forward with the right hand he's
seeing if you're looking at that right
hand he kicks your leg he's going to
move out of the range of your power and
he's like he's thinking in 4d or
something he's he's downloading all your
data and he can see like weaknesses in
people like a great example is paulo
costa paulo costa steamrolled everybody
he was just smashing people he's a giant
dude they called him the eraser he would
just move forward and just [ __ ] a
cracker
and izzy just picked him apart he made
him look made him look foolish yeah and
by the end of the first round you can
see he was baffled like he was [ __ ]
because he knew like i can't hit this
dude and he's standing right in front of
me
and he would he would swing it izzy and
you know izzy would be just out of range
and then he'd make him pay just that
arrangement make him pay and then after
he stopped him he humped him
yeah you know um you know what you know
that where i learned a lot or maybe um
but i watched those uh you see that do
you see that after he he after he
stopped him he humps him watch this yeah
cause he was talking all that [ __ ] yeah
he's talking all that [ __ ] but watch
this
one two
that's why i love izzy man cause he
don't he don't play that [ __ ] well he's
just so slick man if you're like for a
guy like me who's been
interested in striking his whole life
like seeing a guy like this that was a
top flight kickboxer
make his way into mma i reached out to
izzy before he ever fought in the ufc i
saw him fight in uh in kickboxing
matches and i reached out to him on
instagram like way back in the day
and he was telling me that he's taking
some fights to china and he's like he's
gonna come to the ufc but he's gonna do
it the right way he did it the right way
he was smart like some guys jump in but
they don't have a ground game yet they
jump in they don't have defense yet but
they just feel like oh i'm gonna learn a
few things i'm just gonna use my
kickboxing
then you fight some [ __ ] wrestler
some dude who hits you with that power
double and boom when you feel that
weight and pressure like oh [ __ ] i don't
know how to handle this yeah
a lot of guys get [ __ ] up though
you run into a khabib and good exactly
you run into you run into some dagestani
assassin and you're [ __ ] but izzy did
it the right way well i i i watch um i
like watching the you you know the the
morning combat guys yes yeah so luke
thomas and who's the other dude luke's
been on the podcast before he's got that
that dude with him so he he made me
understand
just how much on another level is he is
from everybody else because he breaks it
you know he'll have a two three hour
video where he's like
you know telling you brian campbell
yeah yeah brian campbell yeah they broke
it down one time and i was like oh wow
this [ __ ] is cause i don't you
know because i'm not a big i'm not a i
don't have the experience in fighting
that you have right so i was like
there there needs to be a john madden of
mma you know yeah it made me because at
first i mean i was like watching izzy
but i didn't i didn't get
the chess match that he's playing yeah
that other people just aren't
they're not even aware that there's a
there's another game being played other
than that other than swinging and
kicking right he's on some other [ __ ]
man well he the way he describes it is
like a lot of people are just button
smashers like if you're playing the game
oh yeah trying to make something happen
he's like he's setting things up
he's setting things up and there's other
guys that set things up and that's one
of the things that makes this weekend so
interesting is because he's
on the same card as alex pereira and
alex pereira is beat him he knocked him
out he ko'd him with a left hook in a
kickboxing match
and he beat him once by unanimous
decision and then the rematch at ko dz
you know and uh he's only fought twice
in the ufc but he's won both fights and
now he's fighting the number four ranked
sean strickland this weekend it's very
interesting because they're basically
trying to fast track him to find a fight
with izzy
i'm sorry man you know what
um
i i you got to you have to show me
somebody to beat him well let me show
you somebody um i'm not saying that he
could beat him but alex pereira is one
of the scariest [ __ ] strikers on
planet earth
he's this dude from brazil he's a bad
[ __ ] and this is when he fought
izzy
i think this is i don't know if this is
the first fight of the second fight but
it was a real good fight back and forth
but then this
oh wow
yeah i mean he's got that kind of power
but go to uh alex pereira's highlights
that said the izzy from back then is not
the izzy of today he's way better now
way better now
um
alex pereira who was primarily a
kickboxer two division world champion in
glory now he's made his way over to mma
and he's just so that's we were seeing
that one here
this dude [ __ ] people up and these are
with big gloves on he's one of the most
vicious
knockout artists in glory history like
unusual power
like almost everybody gets starched
and the dude's crazy durable too
like he gets into wars with people and
can they not throw kicks oh they can but
he's
yeah i mean he's got kick knockouts too
but there's a left hand ako dustin
jacoby i mean he's a bad [ __ ]